- Merci Mathieu, on va lui
parler directement.
Bonsoir Monsieur Tremblay.
- Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- On va revenir la structure
archaïque dans quelque temps.
Mais d'abord question
fondamentale : vous avez 40
millions de dollars dans le
trou, en déficit, mais vous ne
voulez pas couper les services.
Vous n'aviez pu deux solutions
pour résoudre cette équation?
- En fait, non. Ce qu'il faut
comprendre, c'est que la
problématique ne découle pas
seulement de la pandémie. On
avait un déficit structurel bien
avant la pandémie. On ne coupait
année par année, et le message
qu'on envoie, c'est de penser
pouvoir couper les dépenses,
c'est impossible de faire ça. On
ne peut plus, on est vraiment au
maximum. Il faut revoir
l'entièreté du modèle financier
qui date de très longtemps. On
ne plus les besoins de nos
ambitions, donc il faut faire
quelque chose. Il est urgent
d'agir selon moi.
- Et d'après vous, qui doit
payer plus? Le client, Montréal,
Québec, les villes?
- Je pense que nos sources de
fonds sont déjà très
diversifiées. C'est un peu la
responsabilité de tout le monde.
On a joué un rôle essentiel
pendant la pandémie. C'est un
vêtement de revoir le mode de
financement. Il y a toutes plein
de choses peuvent être fait.
Après la pandémie, il va y avoir
une crise des changements
climatiques qui va être là, il
n'y a pas de vaccin pour la
crise des changements
climatiques. Je pense que les
transports collectifs... mais je
pense que si on n'y met du sien,
on peut y arriver.
- Si vous le faisiez demain, ça
serait avec des coupes de
service.
- C'est pas ce qu'on veut
faire...
- Mais si c'est ça que vous
disiez de faire, c'est ça que
vous feriez?
- Il y aurait des mises à pied.
Et 90 % des employés ne peuvent
pas être mis à pied. Pendant la
pandémie, ça été un moyen de
protéger les gens. Le service a
permis d'éviter d'avoir des
éclosions dans l'réseau. Parce
qu'il y avait de l'fréquence et
on pouvait respecter le de mail.
Ce n'est pas une raison
d'arrêter le service, et parce
qu'on va reprendre un certain
jour.
- Et ça c'est important, quand
ça va reprendre, est-ce que dans
les conditions actuelles, on va
se retrouver encore avec des
classes sardines, avec des
wagons bondés, s'il n'y a pas de
solution de trouver?
- Si il n'y a pas de fonds
supplémentaires, on ne peut pas
développer le transport
collectif. Et comme toutes les
autres êtres la culture au
Québec qui ont mal vieilli, il
faut les rénover. Et 50
extrêmement chère. C'est très
bien de développer les réseaux,
et on peut ça aussi, mais il
faut s'occuper des réseaux
actuels. Au constructeur de
problématiques. Ça vient aussi
ajouter à la problématique
financière. C'est un peu le cri
du coeur qu'on lance, il y a
urgence à agir.
- Cri du coeur, vous êtes : moi,
je m'en vais. L'agence régionale
de transport métropolitain,
Québec contribue, les clients
contribuent, et ils vous
redonnent l'argent. Vous dîtes
ça, ça ne fait pas de bon sens,
ça ne tient pas la route.
- C'est extrêmement travaillé
comme ça. Vous le savez, vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure. La
STM est la 10e entreprise en
importance du Québec. Gérer une
entreprise comme ça sans
contrôler les dépenses, les
surplus, la dette, ça devient
mon sens très difficile à faire.
La RTM avait été créée pour
veiller à...
- mais ça ne fonctionne pas?
- Non, sa priorité c'est de...
c'est pas seulement la STM qui
le dit. Tous mes collègues des
sociétés de transport dans la
grande région de Montréal sont
du même avis. Il faut qu'il y
ait des changements. Et on veut
que ça soit probant. On n'en
adresse des choses le avant
qu'on soit dans la relance.
C'est le bon temps de s'y
attarder.
- Mais vous, en terminant, vous
dîtes : je ne suis plus capable.
J'ai tout essayé.
- C'était très difficile, mais
il faut aussi penser que j'étais
à ma dernière année de moments :
ça fait 28 ans que je suis à la
STM, huit ans comme directeur
général. C'est un peu comme un
coach hockey. Donc dernier
quelqu'un à la relance, c'est de
bon aloi.
- Il faut qu'il y ait d'autres
sources de revenus, il faut
faire le ménage, etc. Vous
écrirez votre testament au
prochain.
- Refonte en profondeur. On va
pouvoir par la suite sauver la
planète. Je le répète, il n'y a
pas de vaccin pour